pros and cons of standing desks pro
improves ability to talk about having a
standing desk facts the onion is a
satirical news source satirical it's a
joke it pokes fun at us humans we need
to laugh and smile more and not take the
onion seriously because i've seen some
people tweet out onion headlines shocked
as if they were true articles
dr anthony fauci director of the
national institute of allergy and
infectious diseases but a disturbing
report today is revealed that the now
infamous immunologist may actually just
be a figment of the nation's collective
imagination hear more about how millions
of americans are all having the same
exact hallucinations of the so-called dr
fauci
honestly dr fauci is that good that he
could totally be a hallucination do you
know why i know he's not hallucination
because i actually interviewed him dr
mark how are you first of all let me say
a huge thank you for joining us on the
youtube channel everyone in the youtube
community
doctor informs woman
she pregnant as hell
i don't even think this is a real doctor
what is happening here
what is this false identification little
loose leaf paper he has here with no
name and that's a disposable stethoscope
folks why is he wearing it why is there
no name tag why is he have a laser
pointer this is not a person you should
trust pros and cons of standing desks
pro improves ability to talk about
having a standing desk facts two most
common conversations i have with
patients those who are vegan about them
being vegan and those who have a
stand-up desk and want to tell me about
their stand-up desk encourage more
natural spinal curvature while staring
at screen for eight continuous hours
increased blood flow to your feet where
your best thinking
is done that's funny one step closer
toward the ultimate dream of flying
desks
cod could wind up forgetting how to sit
entirely eliminate satisfaction of
leaning back in your chair with your
hands behind your head after sending a
killer email oh that feels good
you'll still eventually die yeah that's
true doctors warn marshawn lynch that
the next time he goes into beast mode
i'm on beast mode right now for this
youtube channel i see this
misinformation and i'm just going beast
me marshawn
cubs team doctor recommends anthony
rizzo rehab injured ankle by engaging in
light physical activities like baseball
professional athletes are professional
athletes but baseball is the definition
of a sedentary activity running around
the bases should be totally fine and is
actually a great way to rebuild strength
there is actually really good exercises
that you can do to rehab and ankle that
are not baseball and a lot of them are
about regaining your range of motion and
then it's about regaining your stability
the ligament that is most often injured
is called the anterior talofibular
ligament and because of that when you
step forward you can lose some of that
uh stability and you could fall forward
beyonce begins painful surgical
transformation to prepare for her role
in live action lion king remake once the
radical alterations her bones
musculature and skin are completed you
won't even be able to tell that the big
old cat you're looking on screen is
actually beyonce the process would begin
with breaking and readjusting the pop
star's spinal column and pelvic bones to
allow her to comfortably walk
quadrupedally never said that word
publicly before there's commitment to
acting and then there's becoming a real
lion and somewhere there needs to be a
medical line that should not be crossed
sick man slowly becoming enthroned in
used tissue must be soft and comfy but
kind of gross because it's mucusy at the
same time local woman considers telling
gynecologist whole truth local woman
denise bowers was mentally calculating
the precise amount of information she
would have to divulge in order to obtain
powerful prescription antibiotics
patients want to divulge as least amount
of information to get what they think is
the accurate treatment that is why
whenever a patient comes into my office
in addition to asking them questions
about their symptoms their history and
doing a physical exam i also ask them at
the end of every visit what is their
theory what do they think is going on
because if they leave my office
unsatisfied or without truly getting an
answer to the question that's deep in
here i'm not doing my job as a doctor
i'm barry bigwell and today we're
talking rob gronkowski after missing
most of the 2013 season with injuries
the loose assemblage of screws
splintered bones and mangled joints that
make up the patriots tight
for a massive comeback there are a lot
of questions surrounding gronk this
fantasy football season but i say ride
that creature to the end i feel like rob
gronkowski is truly a bionic man at this
point not because his surgeries and
fixes that he's had but he just doesn't
go down i remember in the entourage
movie he's like partying with a crutch
and he has like
an injured arm like a broken arm and
he's like still partying i feel like my
shoulder gets sore like i don't want to
get out of bed rob grimkowski
grimkowski's like let's go take some
hits study finds healthy lifestyle can
cut risk of developing alzheimer's by 60
i'm getting sick of researchers
expecting me to do things when they
should be the ones coming up with cures
people must really hate alzheimer's if
they're willing to live a healthy long
life to avoid it so you're saying
there's nothing i can do
in order for us to find cures we need to
figure out what we can do first and then
figure out the mechanism
thereby reducing that risk thereby being
able to implement the cure treatment you
dig latest study finds cancer cells now
cruelly mocking researchers a new mayo
clinic study with widespread
implications for the treatment of
potential cure disease has found that
the malignant growths are basically
flipping off scientists left and right
and get a huge kick out of mocking
oncologists feel like a bunch of
bumbling chumps i would love
if when oncologists or pathologists are
looking under the microscope to see if
the treatments are working and the
malignant cells are just sitting there
like you can catch me you can't catch me
real headline doctors edit living
patients dna for first time i'm just
worried about the moral considerations
of helping sick people greg paulsen is a
window defroster a career it will be a
great day when all doctors can defy
god's plan like this i feel like that's
a drake lyric the field of injecting
things never stops advancing
that's true we like injecting stuff
true headline fda said to approve gene
altering cancer treatment the fda is
expected to approve a new leukemia
treatment that alters a patient's cells
to target cancer cells with hope it
could someday fight other types of
cancer too what do you think i would
only alter my genes to become more
powerful not less sick
so you pay for some fancy treatment but
it's your body doing the actual work
what a scam all of medicine is your body
doing the work literally unless i'm
actively doing a surgical procedure to
fix something and put it together it's
their body doing the work in fact when
the surgeon
connects things we don't even connect it
all the way we usually just like kind of
line it up and let the body heal itself
anyway insurance only covers generic
heart transplant my doctor says it
should work exactly the same as any
other heart it has the same valve same
ventricle same everything aside from
lacking any branding the heart he's
receiving is essentially identical to
the more expensive ones frankly as long
as it keeps on beating i don't care
where it's from this is a play on
generic medications yes generic
medications are
the same as the branded ones when you go
in to buy aspirin and you're like can i
get bayer you're still paying for
aspirin when you say bayer that's a
company that's a brand but you don't
have to buy the brand to get the aspirin
same thing with acetaminophen tylenol is
the brand name of that dr dill shot out
wall and i who's an interventional pain
medicine doctor looked at memes together
he struggled it's worth a watch check it
out here and if you didn't see the
previous episode of my onion medical
reviews click here for that episode as
well and as always stay happy and
healthy
[Music]
you